[Music]
hi my name is elena i'm a pr manager
from ukraine uh hi my name is ann and
i'm a photographer from ukraine right
now we are sitting in a bunker like a
bomb shelter in one of the
one of the buildings when you wake up
and you see
all the messages about like that russia
started the war with ukraine and the
troops are coming and the explosions
were in the morning you can't believe
this is for real so it was like the the
very fast decision and we just moved in
and this is basically where we sleep for
the last seven days uh this is basically
um a minus first floor of an old gym
people are now in the houses because we
live in
five
five floors building so people mostly uh
going for the day uh to their places but
they keep
their stuff in the bunkers so when they
hear explosions they immediately go down
the mirrors are with the duct tape so if
the explosion
starts the mirror won't hurt people
we ain't got a shower here
but we have a toilet
which is which is a luxury basically
that's that's how it looks
first few days were
absolutely crazy like
the emotions were overwhelming
um it's very scary uh to contact your
parents after every explosion so praying
your friends are safe it was tough but
now we kind of
used to live with it so we're not that
scared of the sirens sirens like are on
for maybe like each two hours and we
just like okay another siren another
explosion was just like super scared
when it starts to you know sometimes
there's explosion and your walls get
like shaken that's the scary part you
just can't know what to do because like
no one prepares you for this it just
starts like this and now it's your
reality now you live with explosions now
you live in a constant danger and now
you leave with the with the constant
fear that something will happen to your
family or to yourselves everything
changed overnight
and in our shelter
in the first days were
so much people and there was so
they were so kind
so
so sincere and they helped each other
and
[Music]
i think we are really
strong people in ukraine and that is our
power i mean if you sit and cry it
doesn't change anything so if you're
like making yourself crazy thinking
about death all the time
you're not making anything good for
yourself so we are like so far
so far so good so
we have our families we have our plate
our homes but like some people are in a
way way worse situation because people
like some cities are heavily bombed and
people are losing house it's never
saying but like as long as we have what
we have we can stay strong to everyone
in the world we would like to
say
to
listen to the truthful information
because
russia is spreading a lot of fake news
and they like everyone in russia is
believing that
russia is doing some like military
operations saving uh ukrainian people uh
who want to be a part of russia and we
want to say of you russia no one here
wants you and no one here is waiting for
you
we believe in good we know that
the whole world is on our side we
absolutely
believe that we're gonna win very soon
[Music]
[Music]
of course sasha was not an ordinary
person and
he worked against organized crime since
i believe 2002 2003 when russian money
just flowed to europe to uk
and it was very difficult to understand
sometimes what this money came from was
it just real business